[Music]
on this tuesday night protecting people
from extreme heat
lessons learned from bc's tragic summer
people didn't take it as seriously as
they thought and we're all guilty of
that youth who say they were unjustly
restrained at private group homes
snap global news investigates okay
inside chernobyl the dangerous damage
russian forces dug up mystifying the
city's residents and going off before
taking off this is the worst airport on
earth a former nhler highlights major
turbulence at canada's airports
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas good
evening and thanks for joining us we
start with a bombshell report confirming
the deadly impacts of climate change the
heat dome that hit b.c early last summer
killed more than 600 people who died of
heat related illness today the bc
government promised new strategies to
deal with extreme temperatures
if you think about it people dying from
heat it's not a failure of the health
system it's a failure of the way that we
live and it's a certain you know the
more burden we put on the health system
at times like this is more of a
surrogate of how badly we felt in the
way that we're actually sort of planning
our cities and our homes
even though climate change affects all
canadians some are more vulnerable than
others and eric sorensen has tonight's
top story
there had never been a heat wave like it
in british columbia in one week last
june more than 600 people died most were
older almost all were in their homes
often alone in spite of warnings from
forecasters days beforehand the bc
coroner's review found that public
agencies did not respond quickly enough
but neither did british columbians
unaccustomed to taking heat precautions
or just checking on their neighbors
people didn't take it as seriously as
they thought as we perhaps now think we
should have taken it and we're all
guilty of that
the government has announced its first
change an extreme heat warning is being
added to the emergency text alert system
a recognition that the heat dome
trapping high temperatures for days on
end was a crisis that grew gradually
hour by hour warnings will now be
triggered when there is excessive heat
for two days from above 29 celsius in
areas like vancouver to above 35 in the
bc interior and an extreme heat
emergency could be declared after three
days with nighttime temperature
thresholds as well there will be
much more notification much more
in the media if you like and also much
more communication with local
governments
the review calls for more resources such
as paramedics to respond to emergencies
and that more homes should be cooled or
that more cooling centers be created
where the most vulnerable can be brought
building codes may have to adapt houses
built to keep in the heat in canada's
winter climate now trap the summer heat
in regions that have never been
outfitted with much air conditioning now
that's kind of biting us and so
essentially we have to turn around the
way we look at things to make sure that
we're we're able to cool our buildings
effectively as well as heat them up
canada's climate future dictates that
mitigating the effects of heat must
become a priority and not just in bc
certainly heat is not only impacting bc
but provinces across the country
including the territories as well the
extreme heat we saw in 2021 we had never
seen that before but what we do know is
that as the climate changes we will see
that again
and that's something that we need to be
prepared for prepared with new policies
for a cold weather nation to adapt to a
hotter climate eric sorensen global news
in manitoba a search of the sag king
first nation has identified nearly 200
anomalies in the ground near the site of
the former fort alexander residential
school
ground penetrating radar was done in the
community last june work is now underway
to determine whether the findings could
be unmarked graves of residential school
students 190 disturbances in the ground
were found over two sites near the
school pipelines water lines and sewer
lines have all been ruled out
we continue our series investigating the
state of ontario's child welfare system
tonight with a startling figure two
thousand
that is the number of times in a single
year kids and youth in that province
were physically restrained 87 percent of
the time it happened in group homes
where kids live in a communal house with
staff a joint investigation by global
news and aptn also found a pattern of
physical interventions at some privately
operated group homes and youth who say
the use was unjustified carolyn jarvis
shows us firsthand what it means to be
restrained
i'm going to fold you down this whoa
okay is what a restraint can look like
for kids in group homes
this is how you hold somebody in a prone
position a physical intervention the
ontario government only permits as a
last resort and so this is where a
restraint could stop yeah when there's
an imminent risk of harm to a youth or
others a little step down okay whoa
but people who grew up in group homes
told us they're used far more frequently
to get kids to comply for me it feels
like a body check to the floor
ari calero romero who was
developmentally delayed was restrained
69 times during the year and a half he
lived at an ottawa group home
pain it hurts yes
ari lived at a group home run by a
private company called mary homes which
according to our analysis had one of the
highest number of physical interventions
among service providers in the province
my arm snapped ari was 12 in september
of 2019
when he was restrained on the floor yet
again
his account of what happened and the
incident report from workers differs
greatly
what isn't contested is that it ended
with his left arm broken
ari is now suing mary holmes for two
hundred thousand dollars
mary holmes wouldn't comment on the
incident nor its frequent use of
restraints but intends to defend against
the lawsuit it's a very scary experience
especially for kids with mental health
issues
psychologist maurice faruji says
restraints are an ineffective tool that
further damages vulnerable young people
we hear that all the time that they have
been traumatized and they will have
specific flashbacks of experiences when
they were restrained and these will last
throughout their lives it tells me that
adults have lost control what's crucial
says crisis intervention trainer steve
hall is that staff know how to
de-escalate situations carolyn we don't
want to go here and not be triggered
themselves
a vast majority of the situations that i
was involved with or i witnessed could
have been avoided if adults would have
been in better balance emotionally he
says the best restraint
comes from care providers who don't use
force
carolyn jarvis global news toronto
the trial of a dutch man accused of
sextorting and harassing canadian
teenager amanda todd continues today
with her mother on the stand carol todd
testified she first learned about her
daughter's online activities in 2011
when amanda discovered a facebook
profile which was using topless images
of her the account had linked her
friends and acquaintances at school
which carol says pushed amanda to stop
going to school out of fear of being
confronted by students she ended up
taking her own life in 2012. the accused
aiden cobin was extradited to canada to
face trial in 2020 he's pleaded not
guilty to five charges including
extortion and possession of child
pornography
in ukraine outnumbered troops continued
to defend the city of severo donetsk as
russian forces reportedly worked to
deploy reinforcements to help capture
the key eastern hub
the city's mayor says ukrainian forces
have strengthened their positions and
are holding the line but moscow says
troops have been advancing and quote
fully liberated residential areas of the
city russia says it now controls 97
percent of the surrounding luhansk
region in eastern ukraine
u.n nuclear watchdogs have just ended a
visit to chernobyl one of the first
cities overrun in moscow's invasion near
the site of the former nuclear disaster
russian forces stirred up enough soil to
create new radiation hot spots jeff
simple shows us the mess left behind at
one of the world's most toxic places
chernobyl is synonymous with danger
driving into the north ukrainian city
we're warned to keep our windows shut
radiation levels in some spots remain
dangerously high 36 years since the
world's worst nuclear plant disaster
engineer alexander skereta and his
colleagues are responsible for
maintaining the area around the
notorious nuclear plant they're only
permitted to live here 15 days per month
to limit their exposure which makes the
russian military's actions here
difficult to comprehend
the whole world knows about chernobyl he
says
i can't understand the russian brain
what were they thinking after the
russian retreat skereta returned to work
to find this his office like so many
others here ransacked and looted his
computer among the thousands of pieces
of highly sensitive and expensive
equipment either stolen or destroyed
they made a mess of everything he says
chernobyl sits a short drive from the
belarus border and was quickly captured
by russian troops on the first day of
the invasion
this resident says the russians caught
her trying to contact ukrainian
authorities
they forced me to my knees with a gun to
my head she says i thought i was going
to die when the russians finally left
after five weeks she says they strapped
washing machines and other household
appliances to the tops of their tanks
but the greatest damage done by russian
soldiers here might have actually been
to themselves this is the edge of the
so-called red forest in chernobyl and it
has that name because a lot of evergreen
trees here have turned a shade of
reddish orange as a result of the high
level of radiation that exists on the
soil we're only being allowed to visit
here for a few minutes but it seems the
russians stayed here for a few weeks not
only in the red forest but digging
trenches in the soil there are food
containers scattered all around here
they even used some of the sand to make
sandbags
you have to be crazy or stupid to do
that kind of thing do they have a death
wish ask this member of ukraine's
national guard he showed us numerous
examples where the russians trampled
bulldozed and dug up one of the most
toxic places on earth possibly inhaling
the dangerous dust
our informants in belarus told us that
some of the russian soldiers who stayed
in those trenches were later
hospitalized he says ukraine's nuclear
scientists say radiation levels at the
chernobyl site are now safe but the
russian activity disrupted enough soil
to create additional radiation hot spots
the worst case scenario once feared was
avoided but more than two months since
russian troops left this area crews have
barely begun to clean up their mess
jeff semple global news chernobyl
going nowhere fast coming up what's
fueling grueling delays in canada's
airports
travel chaos across canada tonight with
pandemic protocols and staffing
shortages blamed for flight
cancellations and excruciating delays at
airports and passport offices the agony
for passengers was captured by former
nhl ryan whitney in a twitter post
that's since gone viral as abigail
beamon reports the federal government
promises it's working on things but the
bumpy ride might get worse before it
gets better
i'm so in shock at this place it is the
biggest disgrace
known to men viewed close to two million
times this seething rant about toronto's
pearson airport from a former nhl player
is echoing far and wide at a time when
canada's tourism industry needs a boost
there is a 400 person line
with two air canada workers who are
waiting that line about six hours be it
near the end of the line
they closed it they just said oh you
have to go somewhere else are you just
running a security line extreme delays
have frustrated passengers finally
trying to vacation for weeks i'm hoping
that i don't miss my flight so far i'm
okay that's why we came early today you
need to be prepared and you need to be
flexible we're making sure that we're
not booking people on tight connections
while the problems are mostly at pearson
they affect travelers across canada
that's our gateway to europe it's our
gateway to the caribbean and so i'm
having to talk with clients every day
they're weighing the pros and cons of
should we go on this trip to the
caribbean because do we actually want to
travel through toronto pearson blames
passengers being held on planes 53
percent in the last week of may and
calls on the federal government to drop
inbound public health requirements we
could go back to pre-covert normal that
would have a huge impact but then hiring
more staff to to be able to work
security would be obviously very helpful
it was something we could have predicted
and the government should have moved
earlier this is a global context having
said that we have to do something the
transport minister says security weights
are improving but can't say when
everything will be fixed calling it
gradual airline companies have not
returned to full schedule yet
there are still some employees labor
shortage issue
there are some process issues another
equally pressing problem passport
renewal delays the government blames an
unprecedented surge in demand the
opposition says it was totally
predictable service canada hired an
extra 600 people and plans to double
that in the next several weeks and
reassign 600 more with passport
experience but there's no clear answer
as to how soon the backlog will be
cleared with the summer travel season on
our doorstep chris
all right abigail thank you that's
abigail beeman in ottawa
just ahead a golden opportunity for
canada at the summit of the americas
opportunity
prime minister justin trudeau is in the
u.s this week for president joe biden's
summit of the americas in los angeles
and while some countries weren't invited
and others most notably mexico have
opted out analysts say canada is in a
position to strengthen its presence
across the region david aiken is
following the prime minister's trip and
david trudeau's first stop is at norad
headquarters in colorado
chris prime minister justin trudeau and
his defense minister anita anand will be
on the ground at peterson space force
base in colorado springs for just a few
hours pmo officials say there's no
specific announcement associated with
this visit but the prime minister will
be briefed by military officials on
norad's activities and much needed norad
modernization
continental defense and in fact
hemispheric defense is increasingly top
of mind for canada and its allies these
days
russia's invasion of ukraine and
russia's subsequent threats to use
nuclear weapons have heightened those
concerns
indeed one of trudeau's key objectives
when he meets with leaders from the 32
other member nations this week is to
build support in central and south
america for a strong response against
russia so far not everyone in the region
mexico for example has condemned
russia's actions we see an opportunity
analysts also say that with the relative
decline in the united states influence
in south and central america canada has
a golden opportunity to play a bigger
role in helping others with everything
from adapting to climate change to
strengthening democracy and human rights
given the us position on all of this
only makes
canada's potential
role in the hemisphere
not just materially but symbolically
really critical right i mean latin
americans who are struggling for
democracy and human rights they want to
know that there's a there's a big
country in the neighborhood that's on
their side we could be so much more
if we just had the political will
and the interest on the part of the
canadian government to really increase
canada's stature and presence and
reputation in the region and they want
us to play a role now while he's in los
angeles the prime minister is going to
have a meeting with the california
governor gavin newsom the two men are
both progressive politicians and we
expect that they will have an
announcement on a climate change
agreement the pm then heads back home
saturday chris
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
up next families across two continents
united by a canadian war heroes
sacrifice
yesterday on the 78th anniversary of
d-day we introduced the story of harvey
edgar jones a canadian pilot who made
the ultimate sacrifice during the allied
invasion that continues to ripple
through the generations tonight dan
spector brings you part two of that
special story the dead of gratitude owed
and how decades later the son of this
soldier jones managed to save was
finally able to say thank you
the fire was so violent that the bombs
harvey engelberg feels his name bears
responsibility once i had my own kids i
started realizing
the heavy debt that that name gave me
his father cobby engelberg an rcaf radio
operator on a dakota transport plane
survived the aircraft being shot down by
the germans on d-day because pilot
harvey edgar jones stayed at the
controls instead of parachuting out like
the rest of the crew named after the
pilot who saved his father harvey
engelberg feels it's his duty to honor
his namesake i never met him but to be
named after somebody who died and you're
supposed to honor his memory
i mean that's a burden i mean a burden
it's a responsibility how's that but in
spite of his insatiable desire to show
jones's family gratitude he never had
luck tracking down his descendants or
the duhamels french farmers who pulled
his father from the plane's burning
wreckage after the dakota crashed on
their land engelberg has letters his
father exchanged with the duhamels in
later years i will be indebted to you
forever
how do you thank someone for saving your
life so imagine harvey engelberg's
surprise when a handwritten letter
arrived at his montreal home in march
from bassinville france she said i have
pieces of your father's plane would you
like them and then i immediately say
yeah i'm coming to see you
teres ferret and her husband now live on
that farm 78 years after that fateful
night the couple found pieces of dakota
kg 356 while working the land
in april engelberg visited the green
pasture where the plane went down it was
very emotional but it was just amazing
to see these strangers you know 6 000
miles away caring as much as me he
donated the shards of twisted metal to
the juno beach center canada's war
museum in normandy where they will soon
be displayed i honestly couldn't find a
better story for us to be telling
in our museum it was
although engelberg felt some peace his
work still felt unfinished he hadn't
been able to thank harvey edgar jones's
family i almost hit a wall i was trying
that's where we hoped we might be able
to help surely his relatives had to be
out there somewhere my goal in life was
to find out more about him that i could
and one day to thank his family
and here we are
helen peterson is harvey jones's niece
the daughter of his older sister she
knew him as uncle harv
he was my one and only uncle my favorite
uncle you might say finding out someone
was named in his honor she says is a
highlight of her life i'm just getting
all emotional of the whole thing and
just thinking how wonderful it is harvey
edgar jones was first laid to rest in a
well-maintained grave on the farm in
france but was reinterred at the
ranville war cemetery in normandy
alongside thousands of others who never
made it home he got a mention in
dispatches for his heroism but was never
awarded a higher military honor like the
victoria cross
probably the thing that stuck out to me
the most is just that nobody knows
hardly anybody knows his story
three families on two continents forever
connected by an act of bravery still
felt through the generations hope this
canadian hero's story gets a second look
dan specter global news montreal
thank you harvey
that is global national for this tuesday
night i'm chris galas tonight's york
canada shows the dandelions near la
stowell ontario we love seeing your
canada so please email your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks
very much for watching donna friesen
will be back with you tomorrow hope you
have a great evening
[Music]
you